is
[Music]
8.75
uh
[Music]
is
get the fuck out i forget
get out get out go away
dude get out get out get out
get the fuck
7415 buffalo shots fired
[Applause]
nowhere
washington an eagle
shot's fired
it's not an ambulance
trevor's been hit i'm fine
oh you dumbass
they're gonna be on washington and eagle
headquarters seven four five
[Music]
you're okay yeah i'll be good
seven four one five buffalo
you can have everybody slow down it's
okay driver's deceased
you need a tow truck from the supervisor
that slow all units down
seven
i'm out
[Laughter]
down over there if you want to grab it
yeah i'll bring it over yeah and then
we'll just uh block off the intersection
so we'll hit up that one in that one
yeah
three seven one five where are you
how about you
what's up jones
i shot him
i got the camera
[Music]